رساله في لحظه سياسيه مهمه توقيت وسياقا
نداء الجندي الاسرائيلي المحتجز لدى كتائب
القسام جاء بالتزامن مع حدث اسرائيلي مهم
وهو تسلم هاليفي رئاسه الاركاني في جيش
الاحتلال خلفا للرئيس السابق كخافي تاكيد
على ما اعلنه القائد يحيى السنوار قبل
اسابيع من ان هناك نافذه وقت محدوده
للوصول الى صفقه تبادل والا سيغلق هذا
الملف نهائيا وتبحث المقاومه عن ادوات
لتحرير الاسرى جديده
هذه الرساله اتت ايضا بعد عده رسائل
وجهتها كتائب القسام خلال الفتره الماضيه
تهدف في مجملها الى تشكيل ضغط على اصحاب
القرار في دوله الاحتلال لدفعهم الى
التوصل الى صفقه لتبادل الاسرى على غرار
صفقه كالعاد شاليط
بهذا الشكل ومع بدايه الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الجديده في عهد الرئيس اركان جديده لا شك
انها رساله للحكومه الجديده بان ارسل
الحكومه السابقه الثقيل فيما يتعلق بملف
الاثر لا يزال الحاضرا ايضا هذه الرساله
للجمهور الاسرائيلي لمنقسم اليوم نتحدث عن
انجزته الذي هو من شريحه الاثيوبيين
وغير خاف كذلك ما لتوقيت هذه الرساله من
صله بما يجري من توترات في اوساط الاسرى
الفلسطينيين داخل سجون الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في ظل حكومه لتنياه الجديده
التي استقبلت بمظاهرات من قبل عشرات
الالاف من الاسرائيليين وبعيدا عن دلالات
هذه الرساله ومدى تحقق مقاصدها فانها بلا
شك تؤكد حقيقه واضحه مفادها بان ملف
الاسرار سيكون من الملفات الساخنه خلال
الفتره المقبله وائل الدحدوح الجزيره غزه
فلسطين